christina hack is officially off the
market
it's amazing it is it's incredible after
a year of dating e.t can confirm the
hgtv star has married her fiance josh
hall i trust my guy i trust my
intuitions and
so far they haven't steered me wrong
the couple hasn't made a formal
announcement about their ideas yet
but christina has updated her instagram
name to christina hall and added an
infinity emoji and a key emoji next to
josh's name in her bio
it's my life and i need to do what i'm
comfortable with and i need to move
forward and be happy because you know we
have one shot at it so i might as well
make the best of it the couple's
nuptials come just over a year since the
two started spending time together in
march 2021.
last month the flipper flop alum
celebrated their one-year anniversary on
instagram posting this throwback snap
with josh in nashville
along with a more current couple pick
and she captioned the sweet post with
the lyrics to chris stapleton's song
starting over
[Music]
every mile
of course in march 2021 christina was
still in the midst of her divorce from
aunt anstead i'm just keeping a really
open mind and in one day at a time
the home renovation star announced their
split in march 2020 less than two years
after they tied the knot in december
2018.
at the time she shared the split news on
instagram writing quote we are grateful
for each other and as always our
children will remain our priority
the exes share a two-year-old son hudson
it just happened quickly we got back
from our honeymoon found out i was
pregnant and i mean we couldn't be more
excited they finalized their divorce in
june 2021 and ant has since moved on
with renee zellweger of course christina
is also a mom to eleven-year-old taylor
and six-year-old braden whom she shares
with her first husband tarek el
tarik and i we met at work and so we're
used to working together and honestly
it's just i think it comes really easy
to us
last month the former couple's hit hgtv
show aired its series finale it was
revealed that christina was the one who
chose to walk away after 10 seasons
i feel like it's not really fair to you
or myself to continue
still being with you have you really
thought about this i've thought about it
a lot i thought about it more on the
last trip to tennessee and
i think it's what's best
i can't be at these houses for you like
i should
okay um it's been an amazing run and
there's been ups and downs but it's
mostly been fun
but back to christina and josh you know
things happen for a reason
they went instagram official in july
2021 and for josh's birthday in
september the 38 year old tv personality
penned a sweet tribute to her then
boyfriend on social media the very next
day christina confirmed their engagement
updating her instabio with a ring emoji
next to josh's name
[Music]